hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema was läuft
falsch bei der evakuierung in kabul denn
nach wie vor sind etliche menschen am
flughafen totales chaos dichtes gedränge
und inzwischen sind auch tatsächlich
menschen verletzt worden darunter auch
ein deutscher er wurde durch schüsse
verletzt schwebt aber offenbar nicht in
lebensgefahr und soll ausgeflogen werden
und verzweifelte mütter reichen ihre
babys über die köpfe hinweg zu den
soldaten um sie aus dem gedränge zu
retten und diese gewalt die teilweise
dort eben am flughafen stattfindet auch
eben schüsse das schreckt viele nicht ab
und sie strömen nach wie vor zu
tausenden an den flughafen von kabul um
das land zu verlassen denn viele haben
nach wie vor große angst davor was
passieren könnte in einem land unter den
taliban und wir wollen heute über diese
szene reden unter anderem mit vanessa
sie dies am dienstag raus aus kabul
geschafft hat und außerdem mit dr
christian mölling von der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik und
mit susan ecowas die mit ihrer
organisation in afghanistan projekte
unterstützt wenn ihr fragen oder
kommentare habt schreibt sie uns
jederzeit gerne und ich möchte jetzt
hier an dieser stelle schon vanessa sie
begrüßen hallo schön dass du dir zeit
für uns heute nimmst schön guten anfang
besser guten abend antwort so auch
eingeladen macht ich bin mit euch meine
erfahrung auch teilen kann und auch über
die missstände berichten kann aber auch
irgendwie stimmt die problematiken die
nach wie vor frauchen vielleicht erstmal
vanessa wenn du uns schildert wie war
die ausreise für dich am dienstag hast
du das land verlassen am mittwoch bist
du in deutschland angekommen was hast du
für szenen erlebt am flughafen von kabul
es waren einfach aus chicago hatte ich
ja noch ein bisschen zeit darüber
nachzudenken was wirklich passierte am
flughafen haben mich viele verschiedene
nachrichtensender angesprochen ich habe
auch unterwegs gegeben aber wenn man
wirklich darüber nachdenkt was
fasziniert ist was
unnötig man wirklich behandelt worden
dass man hatte diesen deutschen pass hat
darauf gehofft hinzubekommen raus zu
aufzukommen unterdessen kommt man mit
über 1 menschenmassen mannschaft ist
einfach nicht auf den begriff zu finden
wird ich bin ohnmächtig geworden und
ohnmächtig geworden und hab ich nicht
raus geschafft ich habe ungefähr sieben
stunden versucht
raus zu schaffen ich würde aber habe
geschlagen ich habe menschen gesehen die
mit ihrem fuß verstaucht haben die
kinder und zertrampelt worden sind wie
kinder ihre eltern verloren haben ihre
familien verloren haben was waren bilder
sind immer noch glücklich
ich wahrscheinlich nie wieder mal
vergessen fahren wenn ich jetzt auch die
bürger in medien was sind weder den so
schrecklich und was passiert wenn man
denkt und ich sage auch heute noch nicht
ich hab es ist also möglich aufgegriffen
was der dienstag habe ich noch ein
glückstag war es war so schrecklich
aufzukommen es war unglaublich ich
brachte es selber nicht mehr richtig
raus geschafft habe aber ein freund von
mir ja immer noch lange in favre hat mir
ganz neue bilder gezeigt was inzwischen
tränengas verwendet wird und wie man
damit wohl dass viel mehr schüsse ab
gefördert werden und dass pädophile
menschenmassen inzwischen dort vor ort
sind dass man einfach gar keine chance
mehr hat auszubauen das heißt ich kann
mit tatsächlich noch glücklich schätzen
überhaupt es überhaupt geschafft haben
rauszukommen
vanessa wie hast du es letztendlich
geschafft also wie bist du denn am ende
herausgekommen aus diesem chaos ja
tatsächlich habe ich beim ersten versuch
nicht geschafft gehabt ich bin
ohnmächtig geworden und ich haben
irgendwelche männer aufgetragen daran
erinnere ich mich noch wasser ins
gesicht bekommen die ganzen soldat und
alle menschen haben den menschen von
oben wasser ins gesicht zu schütten
damit die leute nicht ohnmächtig werden
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
dass das mit dass ich wurde noch nie ich
war noch nie ein wirkliches leben und
was passieren noch seinem erstmals
geschafft man muss manchmal kann da
nicht einfach
ganz normal rein spazieren und sagen hey
ich hab den deutschen pass oder den
amerikanischen pass kommen dachten fiel
ein nein
also kommt man nicht sagen man muss
wirklich mit gewalt durch und ich als
zierliche junge frau hat versucht mit
meinem bruder und mein partner dadurch
zu kommen aber
das war erstmal unmöglich es war
unmöglich und
in meinem land sind dann auch schüsse
gefallen so dass man gesagt haben es ist
es einfach nicht wert es ist nicht wert
da herauszukommen in lebensgefahr sein
wenn man stirbt das ist einfach nicht
her es muss einen anderen weg geben hier
rauszukommen und nicht wie auch so
unwürdige art und weise dass man sein
leben konnte die schüsse gefallen
irgendwann mann wollte in ordnung
in dem archiv das ist natürlich die
beste art und so eine öffnung zu
kreieren das ist darauf aufgebrochen um
die wurden zwei frauen angeschossen die
wohn vernetzt
blut geflossen kinder haben bestehen
alle alle sind es war überall frei
chaotisch ich bin direkt wieder raus
geraten ist also das war nach mehreren
45 und bin ich wieder raus gegangen und
wollte nicht wissen wir dann mein
fahrzeug über take over unseren mama ist
noch irgendwie sitzen noch dort könnte
gegen einen bewegenden einblick über
auffällige reinhold ruhig bei darauf
bewerben sterbenden bewährt noch weiter
vorn bleiben
und dann hatte ich noch angst um meine
mutter und meine oma und wir sind dann
wieder angelaufen und ich habe man 40
gewesen dass sich die menschen auf den
boden warfen alle also in die verwaltung
und alle natürlich angst hatten vor den
schüssen dass irgendwas muss ring konnte
und erst dann wurde man eben quasi nach
den kosten gefragt und ich habe
natürlich alles versucht den gesprungen
ich habe meine haare gefragt ist nach
meinung von hagens zeigt einfach damit
die leute wissen hier ist jemand fest
und erst dann wurde ich wahrgenommen als
ich um gesprungen bin als welche
andeutung gemacht was ich hoffe dass
meine mama hat seine haare trägt seine
haare nicht dass die frage mich sehen
und ich standen nämlich eh nicht mit wir
werden ohne geschenk fliegen und dann
merkst du dich hier und sie fragen waren
wirklich mitnehmen bitte
dann
bin ich durch und
du warst auch verwandtenbesuchen du hast
auch gerade schon deine familie erwähnt
mit einer kernfamilie bist du glaub ich
zurück aber du hast eben viele verwandte
vor ort mit afghanischen testen ohne
zweiten deutschen pass wie geht es denen
wie es da die stimmung vor ort was hörst
du
das problem ist dass nicht nur menschen
versuchen mit deutschen pässen oder
anderen ausländischen profis irgendwie
durch dieses tor zu kommen und
zinsausgaben zu gelangen mit sagt man
natürlich auch am besten zu gehen
sondern vor allem auch diejenigen mit
dem afghanischen presse haben versuchen
an dieser stelle mit irgendwelchen
rezepten also wirklich ich habe leute
gesehen die
rezepte vorgezeigt haben um
irgendwelche
besucher auch über diesen weg irgendwie
raus zu kommen ich stehe im kontakt zu
ihnen genauso wie ein freund von mir der
jetzt auch auf kosten kommen mit seiner
familie fest steckt
ja sind alle kaum aktivierte wie alle
traumatisiert und ich wirklich nicht
nach worauf ich dir gedacht so auch ich
wirklich ich bin wirklich geschaut
bekommen um zu sagen noch ist nichts
bringt wirklich die ihm eine trockene
sonnige spielen das bringt nichts ist
jemand ist es keine pauschalreise hier
ist meine emailadresse
ich mich hier raus mein die schweizer
ich hab gehört der freund von mir jetzt
dort wird er hat gesagt die franzosen
steigt an die engländer haben ja jetzt
eine neue möglichkeit gefunden über
fahrzeuge die leute abzuholen
interessant er zum flughafen sicher zu
bringen uns über emotionen stocker oder
sonst noch auf die logistik wie viel
anspruchsvoller deshalb wirklich
ich fordere auch das möglich
bewegung zu ziehen und darüber
nachzudenken ob es nicht wirklich geben
auch dieser weg ins besser ist mit in
fahrzeugen wir werden auch darüber in
der sendung später noch sprechen
vielleicht an dich aber auch noch die
frage du hast schon sehr viel sehr
eindrücklich von der stimmung vor ort
geschildert wie war das jetzt
insbesondere mit den amerikanischen
soldaten die haben dich erstmal nicht
durchgelassen sagst du aber an ihren
einem gewissen punkt dann schon
immer als lange erstens sind gefallen
sind und 2 läuft verletzt worden sind
als die menschen schon fast verdoppelt
worden sind uns schon eine ohnmacht
gefallen worden dann erst
jetzt
lässt man irgendwie aber auch ein
sammelt also das will ich noch mal
betonen ich hatte wirklich glück
durchzukommen weil ich vorgestellt die
menschen standen noch viel viel weiter
hinten ich bin ziemlich ich habe mich
besucht durch die ganze menschenmassen
irgendwie durch zu manövrieren zu sagen
hey ich bin ein tastenfeld nach mitleid
mit den frauen liegt in china kein kind
hoch getragen weil eltern verloren haben
das ist wirklich ich will das noch mal
betonen man die leute fragt zurück
gelaufen sind sie zurück gegangen sind
und gesagt man geht ist es das ist es
uns wert es ist sonst nicht mehr zu
sterben auf dem weg zur rettung wir sind
eine lehre oder sonstwas und die
irgendwie auf diese unwürdige art und
weise jetzt nach deutschland oder sonst
wo hin befragt werden soll nein wir
haben uns verdient
wirklich menschen nicht nach hause
gebracht werden ohne geschlagen zu
werden ohne und dass man uns anstiegs
bis man irgendwas auch wie die wege
macht das hat wie gesagt ich will betont
ich habe die kühle möglich glück war
wirklich zu haben es nicht geschafft
vanessa vielen dank für diese wirklich
sehr eindrücklichen schilderungen von
dir und vielen dank dass du heute abend
bei uns zu gast fast
alles gute wir haben nun auch noch mal
einen beitrag der zusammenfasst einen
bericht der zusammenfasst was da gerade
zurzeit in afghanistan in kabul rund um
diesen flughafen los ist ein bericht von
glück war pott
auch am fünften tag nach der einnahme
kabuls durch die taliban strömen weiter
tausende zum flughafen die
zufahrtsstraßen sind verstopft
zahlreiche familien sind aus der provinz
vor den taliban nach kabul geflogen sie
hoffen nun ins ausland zu kommen die
wenigsten haben pässe oder unterlagen
für eine ausweisung
ich sage den leuten sie sollen zu hause
bleiben hierher kommen ist zwecklos es
ist eine verrückte situation
immer wieder kommt es an den toren zur
panik afghanische und amerikanische
soldaten am rande der überforderung
drängen die massen mit gewehrsalven
zurück auf frauen und kinder ein
deutscher zivilist wurde auf dem weg zum
flughafen angeschossen er soll demnächst
ausgeflogen werden heißt es heute in
berlin in dem chaos müssen diejenigen
nie vorab registriert und in
evakuierungs listen eingetragen wurden
hoffen dass sie es unbeschadet zum tor
am flughafen schaffen und die soldaten
sich hinein lassen manchmal können
unsere konsularbeamten die menschen in
50 meter entfernung sehen sagt ein
polnischer diplomat doch sie kommen
nicht an sie heran
inzwischen sind mehr als 18.000 menschen
ausgeflogen worden da von
1640 an bord von bundeswehrmaschinen das
verteidigungsministerium will zwei
leichte transport hubschrauber nach
kabul bringen die die evakuierungs
operation ab morgen verstärken sollen
für den fall dass wir dort einen
holen müssen nach auskunft des
krisenstabs sollen sich noch mehrere
hundert deutsche staatsbürger in
afghanistan aufhalten die auf eine
ausreise warten
wir reden nun mit dr christian mölling
forschungsdirektor der dkp und leiter
des programms für sicherheit und
verteidigung schönen guten abend herr
mühling
wir haben gehört auch im beitrag ist
soll jetzt also der oder der größte das
größte problem ist die dieser weg ans
gate an den flughafen und also wirklich
ganz schlimme szenen die man da sieht
und zwei hubschrauber der bundeswehr
soll nun helfen die menschen zum
flughafen zu bringen die frage an sie
bei diesen massen die man da sid und
auch von den zahlen die man hört wird
das denn ausreichen um da weniger chaos
quasi vorzufinden
die hubschrauber ich glaube ich fange
vielleicht dank noch die schraube sind
nicht dazu da jetzt all die verbliebenen
deutschen die noch in kabul sind zum
flughafen zu bringen das ist eine eine
ausnahmemöglichkeit geschaffen hat für
die leute die man definitiv auf keinem
anderen weg dahin bringen kann dafür
sind die hubschrauber da sie müssen sich
vor schluss sind sehr kleine
hubschrauber damit werden sie nur ganz
wenige menschen transportieren können
also hier versucht man gezielt zwei oder
drei menschen möglicherweise irgendwo
aus kappel rauszuholen das ist aber eine
zusagen nicht ist nicht der standard
verfahren die anderen leute werden
tatsächlich wege finden müssen sich
durchzuschlagen wir haben das eben in
einem anderen beitrag gehört es war eine
zeit lang möglich dass per auto zumachen
und hab ihr fahrzeug jetzt haben sie
aber ein weiterer auch gesehen dass die
straßen verstopft das heißt also sie
werden den letzten die letzten meter
oder auch kilometer an das zurücklegen
müssen
ich glaube
auch das hat der beitrag eben gezeigt es
ist ein totales chaos vor dem flughafen
das heißt also die frage wie
kriegen sie die leute daraus wenn sie
nicht jetzt massiv sozusagen wieder
eingreifen wollen das gar nicht möglich
ist soll die taliban mittlerweile die
stadt beherrschen und sicherlich diese
kontrolle auch nicht abgeben wollen dann
können sie nur noch den flughafen
aufrechterhalten das machen im jetzigen
zeit zur jetzigen zeit die amerikaner
und die kann aber dem flughafen
übernommen betreiben und fliegen von da
aus
und teilen allen anderen spots zu so das
heißt also die deutschen niederländer
wer auch immer daraus fliegen will kann
jetzt mit den amerikanern um einen flug
slot zu kriegen leute raus zu kriegen
das ist halt kein normaler
flughafenbetrieb dort vorstellbar es
kann ja immer wieder dazu kommen dass
der flughafen geschlossen werden muss
weil ist bombenalarm gibt zum beispiel
das war in der vergangenheit der fall so
dass man sich nicht vorstellen kann dass
das sozusagen ein geregelter betrieb in
irgendeiner art und weise der stadt
findet das ist eine evakuierung
operation wo man versucht so schnell wie
möglich so viel wie möglich menschen aus
dieser situation raus zu bringen und ich
glaube es ist auch allen klar man wird
nicht alle menschen rauskriegen die
amerikaner selber haben mehrere
zehntausend menschen noch in allein in
kabul und der umgebung die sie noch raus
bringen müssen deswegen haben die
natürlich ein erhebliches interesse
daran so viel wie möglich in bewegung zu
setzen
und die deutschen haben neben den
mehreren hundert erwähnt worden sind
wohl noch einige andere menschen nur
ausgemacht wir müssen das gleiche thema
das man halt gucken muss wie schafft man
es fair verteilt so viele menschen wie
möglich aus dem land heraus suchen sie
haben es angesprochen als so ein
bisschen die devise der amerikaner auch
so viele wie möglich so schnell wie
möglich und die haben da auch schon also
mehr als 9000 menschen rausgebracht
deutschland rund 1600 wie konnte das
sein dass da jetzt die kontrolle so
stark bei den amerikanern liegt wie so
nicht mehr koordination vor ort von den
internationalen auch also ich kann
nichts zu der der koordination vor ort
sagen die tatsache ist dass die
amerikaner ohne die amerikaner würden
wir diesen flughafen gar nicht
beschreiben können weil die amerikaner
mit einer erheblichen zahl von mehreren
tausend soldaten wieder zurückgekommen
sind was sie gesehen haben sie einen
fehler gemacht haben okay alles klar
wenn wir unsere leute noch aufholen
wollen dann müssen wir diesen flughafen
halten das hat man sicherlich mit
abstimmung mit den taliban getan das
heißt dass jetzt nichts wo man das
sozusagen einfach sich rück überfallen
hat das ganze und zurückgeholt hat
sondern wo man tatsächlich gesagt hat
das ist ein kompromiss der mann
offensichtlich gefunden hat aber der
kompromiss kann work gehalten werden und
sozusagen der flughafen auch nur
weiterbetrieben werden wenn sie das
chaos vor den toren lassen das ist
schrecklich weil wir haben es ja den
bildern gesehen dass eine schreckliche
szenen die wir den letzten tagen immer
wieder gesehen haben was vor dem
flughafen passiert aber wir erinnern uns
vielleicht auch an die szenen der ersten
stunden der evakuierung als menschen auf
das flugfeld gelaufen sind teilweise
sich an dem flug an flugzeugen
festgehalten haben und runter gefallen
sind wir sind hier in der situation
wo klar ist es werden nicht alle
menschen überleben und das bringt
natürlich alle in den in den wahnsinn
weil die natürlich alle spüren wie komme
ich hier überhaupt noch mit dem daraus
oder nicht die leute sind verzweifelt
aber wenn sie überhaupt noch menschen
retten wollen über diese luft dann
müssen sie tatsächlich gewährleisten
können dass sie an diesem flughafen rund
um die uhr fliegen können denn nur so
kriegen wir die menschen aus dem land
noch irgendwie raus zumindest aus der
gegend von kabul das muss man ja auch
sagen wir ihnen jetzt sagt nur um die
gegend von kabul warum die amerikaner
eine höhere zahl haben als die deutschen
kann ich ihnen nicht sagen ich glaube es
gibt sehr viele gründe dafür aber das
wäre jetzt reine spekulationen zu sagen
die deutschen sind schlechter mit den
listen und die amerikaner lassen leute
nicht durch wir haben keine
systematische lage das heißt wir haben
viele einzelberichte als er berichtet
ich auch wiederholt werden von vielen
medien wohl nicht klar ist sagt dass die
gleiche person und wird 50 mal zitiert
oder sind es 50 personen und wir haben
tatsächlich ein problem auch die gründe
warum bestimmte sachen die stattfinden
können wie gesagt wenn sie ein
bombenalarm haben dann steht erstmal
alles still dann muss der flughafen den
bestimmten bereichen geräumt werden das
ist halt eben nicht wie berlin oder wie
frankfurt oder sonst irgendwas normaler
flugbetrieb
wo es darum geht tatsächlich so viele
menschen wie möglich hier aus zu kriegen
wenn ihr fragen habt an herrn ling dann
schreibt sie gerne bei uns im stream und
chat dann habe ich die möglichkeit sehen
noch zu stellen ich will noch kurz auf
eine sache eingehen sie hatten
angesprochen hämmerling dass es war vor
ein paar tagen ist war es noch möglich
sich mit fahrzeugen auch zu bewegen in
dem jetzigen chaos ist da nicht mehr
viel zu machen da vielleicht auch die
frage wieso wurde da nicht mehr diese
chance genutzt von seiten jetzt von
deutschland aus als das vielleicht noch
ging da irgendwie ein bisschen mehr
ordnung reinzubringen
das kann ich ihnen ehrlich gesagt nicht
sagen es ist eine entscheidung der der
menschen vor ort oder eine frage der der
risikoabschätzung die ich nicht die ich
nicht treffen kann oder die die von der
ich nicht weiß wie sie getroffen worden
ist eine situation in der die
das deutsche kommando vor ort
entscheidet was sie am besten macht und
wie sie die leute aus wir haben einige
sozusagen kues gesehen wo franzosen
briten italiener das geschafft haben ich
weiß nicht wie viel die so raus bekommen
haben ich kann zurzeit nicht sagen ob
die deutschen in dem punkt zu ist doch
mal sagen fehler gemacht haben und zu
zurückhaltend gewesen sind oder aber ob
man ähnliches versucht hat und wir
einfach davon nichts nichts gehört haben
weil das muss man sich ja auch
vorstellen wenn wir berichten in den
deutschen medien entweder über gelungene
kues dass wir leute rausgeholt haben
oder dass wir jetzt hubschrauber dahin
transportieren und wie viele wieder den
transport etc dann gucken uns gerade
hier bei dieser sendung natürlich
taliban zu und sagen okay was passiert
darin jetzt gerade das ist nicht in
unserem interesse und werden versuchen
das zu stoppen das heißt also bestimmte
sachen ist es in solchen situationen
besser es nicht zu erfahren und nicht
darüber hielt sozusagen auskunft zu
geben ich kann es auch gar nicht aber
auch das sozusagen die bundesregierung
an bestimmten punkten sagt darüber reden
wir nicht weil wir gefährden damit im
grunde genommen die evakuierungs
möglichkeiten die wir haben und ich
glaube es ist relativ klar dass unter
den jetzigen bedingungen zumindest nicht
mehr möglichkeiten geben wird die leute
zum flughafen zu bringen denn je länger
die uhr läuft umso größer wird die panik
sicherlich in der stadt seien überhaupt
irgendwie aus dem aus dem aus der stadt
raus zu kommen und es wird gerüchte
geben was es noch an möglichkeiten gibt
wir werden die ganze menge an ja auch an
falschinformation haben die haben wir
jetzt schon älter und völlig klar ist so
werden wir im grunde genommen nur
weniger möglichkeiten haben menschen
raus zu bringen und nicht mehr menschen
haben die anfragen für sie im stream zum
einen möchte gerald schreiber bei
facebook wissen wieso konnte das keiner
absehen sich darauf vorzubereiten auf
das chaos na ja das haben sie gerade
auch schon so ein bisschen eigentlich
mit beantwortet
naja also vielleicht sich die frage doch
mal da war ich spekuliert auch sozusagen
hätten wir nicht sagen diese evakuierung
an sich vorhersehen können und ich
glaube dazu hat die die bundesregierung
hat ihre fehler eingestanden ich glaube
wir werden wir werden sicherlich eine
kommission nach einen
untersuchungsausschuss zu dieser frage
haben denn natürlich ist es relativ
unglaublich dass es nicht möglich
gewesen ist das vorher zu sehen also
spätestens als man gesehen hat nicht
schnell die taliban vorangekommen sind
war es also zumindest in den ofen sich
schlecht informierten kreisen die mein
kollegium schon
steigende wahrscheinlichkeit absehbar
dass man wahrscheinlich eine evakuierung
operation rein rennen würde aber ich
glaube ich muss man ganz klar
unterscheiden zwischen dem was auf der
einen seite sagen wahrscheinlich ist und
die frage ob noch politisch bereit ist
das signal zu senden aber das ist das wo
man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt sagen muss
darüber werden wir uns hoffentlich
sehr intensiv unterhalten können wenn
die evakuierungs operation zu ende ist
zurzeit zählt in der tat erst mal die
menschen da rauszuholen aber die
politischen fehler die gemacht worden
sind müssen aufgearbeitet werden und
dass man auch sagen muss ist auch die
die frage welche möglichkeit müssen wir
in zukunft eigentlich haben um deutsche
staatsbürger zu retten wird sicherlich
auch etwas sein wo man sich fragen muss
ob der bundestag und auch die
bundesregierung sich in zukunft noch mal
gedanken darüber machen müssen ob wir
nicht tatsächlich eine viel höhere
bereitschaft ist ein bereitschaftszeiten
bereitstehende soldaten und truppe haben
müssen von mir aus auch polizei das ist
mir egal aber
professionell menschen die in der lage
sind dann tatsächlich schnell zu
reagieren egal um welche tageszeit und
ob es an bord
es gibt noch mehr fragen benjamin
gärtner möchte bei youtube gerne wissen
wie sieht es mit der zusammenarbeit
europäische soldaten mit us-soldaten aus
ich glaube dass auch allgemein gefragt
also ich glaube dass das generell gibt
es gibt sozusagen austausch zwischen den
zwischen den kommentieren das ist glaube
ich sozusagen was schon da ist was das
große problem einfach ist ist dass sie
einfach an den flughafen
unübersichtliche lage haben wo sie nicht
gewährleisten können dass jeder befehl
oder jede idee die man hat gesagt wir
machen wir jetzt eigentlich sagen die
einlasskontrolle täter dass das immer
sehr einfach umgesetzt werden kann das
aber glaub ich klar ist ist in dem in
dem bewusstsein in dem dieser operation
seit 20 jahren durchgeführt worden ist
also wir sind zusammen eingegangen wir
gehen zusammen raus das ist ja was was
die nato staaten untereinander geprägt
hat über 20 jahren also dazu glauben
dass sozialer seinen persönlichen
vorteil das ist glaube ich nicht so es
bleibt dabei dass alle versuchen ihre
leute da rauszukriegen dass das nicht
immer super gelingt das teil also immer
noch flugzeuge wieder leer zurück
fliegen auch das ist ein teil der
wahrheit was einfach damit zu tun hat
dass zb
wenn sie zu einem bestimmten flug soll
rein fliegen aber keine leute da haben
sowie das deutschland zwischendurch
offensichtlich mal passiert ist dass sie
dann tatsächlich wieder rausfliegen
müssen wir das nächste flugzeug ist das
ist eine luftbrücke das heißt da können
sie nicht einfach packen und sie fliegen
zum geld oder so und können da warten
bis alle eingestiegen sind sondern sie
müssen natürlich sehen dass die relativ
zügig ihre leute haben und wenn die
nicht da sind ja dann müssen sie eben
wieder rausfliegen und
noch mehr fragen jetzt hier immer mehr
fragen ein und zwar der lone wolf möchte
bei youtube wissen wie wird deutschland
reagieren falls den ksk mitgliedern und
oder den zu retten während der
rettungseinsätze etwas zustößt was die
person natürlich freilich nicht hofft
dass das kann ich nicht sagen dass wir
wahrscheinlich noch wenn ich es wüsste
würde ich es ihnen nicht sagen weil das
würde ja anderen leuten erklären trafen
sich vorbereiten können ich weiß nicht
ob das super ist ich kann ihnen sagen
was deutschland nicht machen wird dass
wir die luftbrücke nicht einstellen
dass das glaube ich dass das wichtigste
natürlich ist es ein risiko sich ganz
klar vorstellt egal wie es kann sein
dass wenn die situation noch schwieriger
wird weil die taliban sagen wir möchten
eigentlich nicht mehr dass das
weitergeht so
dass es dann möglicherweise zu verletzt
nun zu toten kommt aber auch das muss
man sich glaube ich vor augen führen das
ist eine besondere situation für die die
soldatinnen und soldaten erstens
ausgebildet sind und sie kennen das
risiko sie sind es in der vergangenheit
immer wieder eingegangen
und das ist glaube ich der punkt wo man
sozusagen es dafür dafür haben wir
tatsächlich soldaten menschen die bereit
sind um die einleiter auf geleistet
haben im zweifelsfalle für dieses land
zu sterben um deutsche interessen
durchzusetzen das deutsche interesse ist
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt so viele
zivilisten wie möglich aus diesem land
auszuführen also wie gesagt ich glaube
dass eine wird nicht passieren das
können wir uns es wäre unvorstellbar
dass wir tatsächlich aufhören würden die
luftbrücke zu betreuen
wir haben auch noch fragen natürlich
zudem davor um bis hin zu verstehen
warum wir jetzt eigentlich die situation
so haben wir sie ist das kann ich gut
verstehen dass da
einfach noch viele fragezeichen sind und
zwar möchte sabine behringer bei
facebook wissen seit monaten wird auf
diplomatischem weg versucht verhandlung
mit den taliban zu führen warum kommt
die machtübernahme plötzlich
überraschend für die politik das ist
doch nicht mehr nachvollziehbar schreibt
sie
ich glaube es ist ein kann dem recht
geben es ist in bestimmten punkten nicht
nachvollziehbar das hat ja auch zu
dieser großen ich glaube erst als
überraschungsgast ration und trauer
geführt die wir in den letzten
tagen glaube ich alle oder viele
menschen erlebt haben das ist mir nicht
anders gegangen
die dass die taliban auf der einen seite
indoor verhandelt haben über einen
friedensvertrag und auf der anderen
seite politiker sprach gegangen sind ist
jetzt nicht unüblich dass du zu machen
denn sie haben zwei optionen wenn die
eigentlich funktioniert also sie
militärisch nicht die die gewinne
kriegen die sie haben wollen dann machen
sie es auf dem verhandlungsweg aber
gleichzeitig braucht man im
verhandlungsweg natürlich nicht mehr
wenn man militärisch genau die lösung
erzielt hat die man nicht erzielen
wollte das ist natürlich und das muss
man aber deutlich unterstreichen
kein politisches diktum dass in
deutschland irgendwie akzeptiert ist
dass man militärisch seine ziel erreicht
was auch in diesem fall passiert ist die
taliban sind durchgegangen haben keine
zwei wochen gebraucht und sind in kabul
gewesen und wir haben tatsächlich
geglaubt
dass sie das nicht machen weil es ja
unser eigener anlage ist das für
politische probleme politischen lösung
angewandt werden das ist in diesem fall
nicht der fall gewesen und vielen
anderen beispiel der letzten jahre auch
nicht der fall gewesen das heißt also
hier gibt es wohl eine gewisse
blauäugigkeit nicht nur der deutschen
politik auch in einer anderen politik
also in anderen ländern was da glaube
ich noch mit dazugehört ist
persönlicher beobachtung ich glaube
schon dass alle das land verlassen
wollten weil klar war dass man
hier im grunde um keinen erfolg mehr
haben kann
spätestens als die amerikaner gesagt
haben begehen war auch klar okay wir
alleine können es wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr schaffen zweiter gedanke den ich
dann noch anknüpfen möchte wir sehen
zurzeit nur militär afghanistan ist sehr
lange nicht nur eine militärische
sondern auch eine zivile wiederaufbau
arbeit gewesen eine entwicklungshilfe
arbeit gewesen alles das ist jetzt auch
beendet und auch alles das steht in
frage wie ob wir das in zukunft noch
einmal leisten können
und ob wir den mut haben tatsächlich
international weiterhin zu wirken aus
meiner sicht ist es notwendig wir können
nicht einfach sozusagen die schotten
haben und sagen wir mit dem rest der
welt nichts zu tun dass wir diese form
von isolation hier ist einfach nicht
denkbar aber ich glaube dass wir eine
debatte darüber haben werden die alles
das hinterfragen wird warum wir das
gemacht haben und wie das in zukunft
machen wollen das einfach ist natürlich
zu sagen wir machen das einfach nicht
mehr was ist schief gegangen das wird
glaube ich auch nicht gelingen
vielen dank herr mailing an dieser
stelle genau über diese hilfsarbeit vor
ort möchten jetzt sprechen mit susanna
niveau was aber erstmal vielen dank an
sie hämmerling dankeschön ebenso
und genau über dieses wichtige thema die
hilfe vor ort und wie die aktuelle
situation ist möchten wir sprechen mit
seiner liebe was gründerin der
hilfsorganisation kinderberg und sie
organisiert seit fast 20 jahren eben vor
allem medizinische projekte für frauen
und kinder vor allem in der region
feisabad guten abend frau die bereits
guten abend freuen die wir haben auch
schon tatsächlich sehr viele fragen an
sieben streamen aber vielleicht erstmal
dass wir noch ein bisschen besser
verstehen was sie da genau machen vor
ort was ihre arbeit da genau ist was ist
das können sie ein bisschen beschreiben
und auch wie es ihren mitarbeiten denn
jetzt gerade vor ort nämlich geht
ja wir sind seit 20 jahren schon in
afghanistan tätig und wir haben schon
von anfang an immer unser hauptaugenmerk
auf frauen und kinder gesetzt weil das
land war hatte die dritthöchste kinder
und müttersterblichkeit rate der welt
als wir dort ankamen
und das haben wir in den letzten 20
jahren verbessert und das wurde nur
verbessert durch eine einzige sache
indem das frauen bildung bekommen haben
denn diese hohe kindersterblichkeitsrate
die liegt daran darin begründet dass die
taliban vor 20 jahren nicht zugelassen
haben dass frauen bildung erfahren dass
es hebammen gibt krankenschwestern
frauenärztinnen gibt und dass die frau
die ja in ihrer familie dafür sorgt dass
die kinder ja auch hygienisch oder gut
versorgt sind das ist eben die frau das
ist der wichtigste kern einer
volkswirtschaft
kinder gesund zu erhalten um kindern
auch selbst bildung zusammen sie lernen
dass von ihren mit und sie werden von
denen gesund gehalten und die es ist ein
fürchterliches
leben und in diesem land wenn man als
frau angst haben muss zu entbinden
das war das war das was wir angefangen
haben und wir haben in dieser zeit
[Musik]
wir haben in unserer hochphase 96.000
patienten pro monat gehabt 30 millionen
euro vom auswärtigen amt umgesetzt und
so genannte baby care stations gehabt
bis heute die unterernährte kinder haben
risikoschwangere aber auch waisenhäuser
unterstützt und frauen in gefängnissen
deren einziges vergehen war dass sie
unverheiratet schwanger waren so kam es
in die gefängnisse und wie geht es ihren
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern jetzt
gerade vor ort in afghanistan
also
ich lebe da gerade ein sehr schädlich
ich erlebe das ist schon wirklich
schizophrenen zwei völlig
unterschiedliche informationen die wir
bekommen
für mich ist alles das was wir jetzt hin
auf ganz dann sehen vorhersehbar gewesen
es gibt nur zwei überraschungen für mich
die eine ist wie schnell es ging und die
andere ist wie die taliban sich heute
verhalten das waren eher davon
ausgegangen können sie das weiter
ausführen wie die taliban sich jetzt
verhalten
ich bin davon ausgegangen dass die
taliban wieder es durch die straßen
morgen ziehen werden die leichen durch
geben was hinterher ziehen
dass sie gleich frauen
steinigen die für uns gearbeitet haben
und das ist alles nicht passiert und
zwar bis heute nicht passiert und ich
spreche jetzt nicht
nur vom cabrio und was er jetzt erst
kürzlich in die hände der taliban
angefallen ist sondern ich spreche von
kundus es ist die erste stadt in der wir
tätig sind die in die hände der taliban
gefallen lässt
wir sind im nordosten und dann faisabad
und
ich dachte das ebenfalls abad ist eine
mehrheitlich schiitische bevölkerung
dass der widerstand dort stärker und
größer sein wird und wir haben noch zwei
tage bevor die taliban faisabad
angenommen haben haben die
regierungstruppen ein taliban kommandeur
getötet und ich war mir ziemlich sicher
dass die rache blutig sein wird es war
sofort ruhig also die tage der vorwahlen
kämpfe die schlinge hat sich immer
weiter zugezogen wir haben das seit
wochen mitbekommen wie die distrikte
gefallen sind und das regierungs truppen
gekämpft haben und nach auf nachschub
gehofft haben und dringend darum gebeten
haben wir nichts kam aus kabul gar
nichts also so lange in doha verhandelt
wurde kam da waren die kämpfe in immer
einzelne immer mehr distrikten da und es
kam keine hilfe kein nachschub und da
hat man schon gedacht da in doha wird
irgendwas verhandelt und der norden es
verkauft auch für irgendetwas was
kriegen wir jetzt in doha dafür
verhandelt man jetzt vielleicht in doha
das taliban in die regierung kommen und
sie sagen als geht aber nur wenn wir uns
den norden gibt auf jeden fall waren sie
waren die kämpfe immer näher und wir
haben tagelang war die stadt belagerte
ich die ganzen zufahrtsstraßen waren in
den händen der taliban
wir haben kontrolliert ob jemand raus
und rein geht ob lebensmittel rein und
rausgehen und jeder wusste die sind an
der macht die können rein kommen wann
sie wollen und die a- und so haben sie
wirklich von tag zu tag diese angst war
immer größer und größer und dann auf
einmal ja diese nacht in der dann die
die stadt gefallen ist am nächsten tag
eine stille und ruhe
unglaublicher und es wurde die
sperrstunde eingeführt und zwei tage
später waren die bei uns im projekt in
unserem
patienten haus und wir haben alle
patienten evakuiert wir hatten auch
geflüchtete die verletzt waren aus
kundus an die evakuiert werden wir haben
nur noch zwei wächter dort gelassen und
irgendwie dachte ich mir was ich denn da
wenn so
taliban kommt an kriegsbeute ich dachte
wenn ich jetzt vielleicht ein auto
umparken autoren das bargeld und total
us unternehmen die das und gibt es
weniger rache ich habe gar nichts
gemacht haben wirklich angeklopft salam
aleikum gesagt sind rein gegangen haben
sich angeschaut was wir machen was im
übrigen schon längst wussten also die
bewussten schritt hengst wer wir sind
nach 20 jahren was wir tun haben wir uns
für unsere arbeit gedankt und gesagt wir
sollen bitte so schnell wie möglich
wieder anfangen zu arbeiten und dass die
frauen arbeiten soll
und das hat überraschung und wie passt
das zusammen aber auch mit den ganzen
berichten die wir in den letzten tagen
und ja in den letzten tagen hören von
frauen die sich verstecken von frauen
die eben teilweise berichten dass sie
schon nicht mehr zur arbeit kommen
dürfen es scheint mir da tatsächlich so
ein bisschen sehr gespalten vielleicht
zu sein wie schätzen sie das ein
also ich telefoniere auch mit frauen die
in kabul sind das habe ich auch gemacht
vor dieser sendung und
und auch in kundus ich glaube dass die
taliban sich tatsächlich entwickelt
haben also nicht verändert haben sondern
sie haben auf ihren gedanken wie man
einen staat führen sollen scharia etwas
aufgesetzt an annehmlichkeiten die sie
nicht hergeben wollen und und taliban
hat eben auch eine frau und will kinder
und double seiner seine söhne gesund
sind und die haben in den 20 jahren
gesehen dass das noch geht und frauen
arbeiten und warum bin ich ja
entschuldigung darf ich aber ja ich
würde uns noch mal ein haken weil ich
bei tatsächlich bei twitter von vielen
frauen auch schon tatsächlich berichte
gelesen habe auch eine journalistin die
aber das gegenteil berichtet haben die
gesagt haben wir haben jetzt gesagt wenn
sie dürfen nicht ja ja ja das ist eben
der das ist eben die diskrepanz ich
glaube dass die taliban sich gerade
rauspicken welche frau für sie sinn
macht nützlich ist und welche nicht also
die medizinisch tätigen frauen und im
sozialbereich die werden sie arbeiten
lassen krankenschwestern hebammen aber
auch natürlich wir sind die in
vollverschleierung zur arbeit kommen und
männlicher begleitung da also arbeit
gehen aber was sie nicht so brauchen
sind journalistinnen und
frauenrechtlerinnen das und das sehe ich
wirklich da sind frauen die oder solche
die in der politik waren
da glaube ich dass diese frauen wirklich
gefährdet sind aber ich habe und diese
ängste verstehe ich der frauen jetzt
möchte ich aber noch zur evakuierung
gekommen ich habe in diesen 20 jahren
ungefähr
750 unterschiedliche menschen bei mir
arbeiten gehabt und x 54 genommen können
müssten eigentlich die personen die
jetzt für eine deutsche
hilfsorganisation gearbeitet haben
nämlich meine das wären schon allein
dreieinhalb oder 4000 die jetzt sagen
weil sie für eine deutsche organisation
der arbeit haben möchten sie auch
evakuiert werden und das ist mein
problem und die machen sich auch auf den
weg ich bekomme seitdem dieser
luftbrücke begonnen hat versuchen diese
leute und jeder will afghanistan von
lassen in der hoffnung weil sich für uns
gearbeitet haben dass ich da irgendwie
hin kommen ich habe ein fahrer der seit
fünf tagen vor dem kabuler flughafen und
der mir sagte hier ist meine
emailadresse schreibt eine e-mail mit
einer e mail kommt man rein es kann
nicht sein und
was sehr viele menschen von diesem
flughafen auch weg bringen würde und ich
habe die berichtet dass im moment so 600
bis 700 tausend menschen um den
flughafen sind es kommen immer mehr auch
aus den provinzen wäre dass man sagt wer
überhaupt kommt noch auf eine luftbrücke
volk überhaupt rein ich weiß nicht wer
von den drei einhalb oder 4000 als ich
sagt meine mitarbeiter mal der fünf oder
sieben während ihre familie
wer würde überhaupt alle chips sein
könnte rausgehen das heißt diese
diese masse von leuten die jetzt gerade
vom flughafen steht ist eine masse von
menschen auch die angst haben vor der
zukunft das sind nicht alles menschen
die heute bedroht werden wir sehen und
hören nicht von frauen die gesteinigt
werden und das was vor 20 jahren war die
taliban einen guten grund das nicht zu
tun da kann man vielleicht nachher noch
darüber reden
aber ich glaube dass es gut wäre eine
dieser evakuierungs liste zu
konditionieren und jetzt zu sagen wer
wird denn überhaupt auf diese liste
kommen nehmen sie allein meine
organisation kommt da jemand drauf der
für mich drei wochen gearbeitet hat vor
zehn jahren oder kommen da andere leute
drauf und dazu habe ich eine frage im
mainstream wenn ich die auch direkt
stellen darf niklas kreis breunig bei
youtube möchte nämlich gerne wissen wie
sieht die aktuelle lage der ortskräfte
aus wird jetzt jeder evakuierte aus
afghanistan raus möchte oder hält man
weiter am system keine angestellten von
subunternehmen et cetera fest ja das ist
eben die frage wie ich mich auf die ich
mir auch stelle und nicht für mich für
meine organisation war schon mal klar
wenn man sagen würde und er weiß von
ihnen kommt keiner raus oder nur
bestimmte leute raus soll dann würde ich
diese information streuen und es wären
sofort ein paar weniger auf dem weg zum
flughafen und andere die dort sind
würden wieder kehrt machen und dann wäre
die frage für die die auf diese liste
kommen nehmen wir mal an
frauen die seit mehr wie ein zwei jahren
in führungspositionen arbeiten solche
zum beispiel das weil die taliban ungern
frauen in führungspositionen sehen dann
die alte manager sind und die die ich
auch auf universitäten geschickt habe
wenn die auch journalistisch währung
dann ist die frage wie kommen die dann
sicher zum flughafen
aber dann könnte ich diesen frauen schon
mal sagen ihr seid auf der liste und
jetzt passt gut auf vorhersagt haltet
euch ruhig wir holen euch raus wir es
noch nicht wie aber ganz ruhig hat die
drehen sonst durch bis zu dem tag wo was
kommt oder sie gehen auf dem flughafen
uns passiert ihnen das was wir gerade
gehört haben also das wäre schon mal
eine entspannung denke ich in der lage
hier ist auch noch eine weitere frage
von ulrike bei facebook dies die lage
für kinder haben die eine möglichkeit
geschützt zu werden
also die taliban selbst haben nicht vor
das haben sie auch vor 20 jahren nicht
gemacht die taliban selbst den nicht
jetzt gewalttätig gegen kinder
vorgegangen das sind sie nicht aber die
nächste große katastrophe bahnt sich an
ich glaube das ist auch ein grund warum
die taliban jetzt frauen arbeiten lassen
wir haben bald in manchen regionen
afghanistan ist bald der winter da muss
man so bis ende oktober anfang november
schon die vorräte in den häusern haben
nach oben im nordosten bahnkorridor das
so damit sind die lebensmittel da seien
die lebensmittel werden jetzt schon
knapp der afghani ist im wert gesunken
es kommen die lebensmittel die dieses
land braucht nicht mehr so von außen
rein die preise sind gestiegen
die gehälter werden nicht ausgezahlt die
banken waren zu und deshalb brauchen die
taliban die jetzt auch ausgeschlossen
wurden von
entwicklungshilfe die brauchen schon
jetzt im besten fall wer bild in so ein
land regierung an das volk hungrig ist
und der winter vor der tür steht und
ein beispiel jetzt aus weißer bart ist
letzte woche wurden in faisabad das
frauengefängnis in dem wir tätig waren
einfach aufgelöst die taliban sind
gekommen um alle frauen aus dem
frauengefängnis ausgelassen ebenso haben
sie das waisenhaus in faisabad aufgelöst
und die waisenkinder was im übrigen
jungs sind
einfach sie haben gesagt urlaub nach
hause geschickt ja aber was ein zuhause
wenn es ein waisenhaus war oder wieso
haben die neben
der grund der dahinter steckt ist dass
auch diese regierungsbeamten nämlich die
die im gefängnis die haben auch alle
angst gehabt vor den taliban und sind
erstmal verschwunden und sie sind nicht
zurückgekommen zur arbeit und sie
bekommen kein gehalt wer soll denn jetzt
diesen ganzen regierungsbeamten und bern
awp sda der leiter eines waisenhauses
oder ein gefängnisdirektor ist sein
gehalt zahlen und wer soll diese
waisenkinder und die frauen im gefängnis
ernähren oder ihre medizinische
betreuung aufrechterhalten schauen sie
mal an werde auf der straße ist und wer
von aufgaben wer fliehen will das sind
ja nicht die taliban die jetzt viel
leben wollen und das sind nämlich auch
nicht menschen die nicht gearbeitet
haben wir sind menschen die für die
regierung gearbeitet haben und diesen
staat mit allem wasser in den 20 jahren
an verbesserung und hat aufrecht
erhalten hat wir haben ein
wasserkraftwerk in afghanistan gebaut
uhr und da diese energie die dieses
kraftwerk die wollen die auch haben aber
es gibt kein taliban der dieses
wasserkraftwerk technisch in schuss
halten kann das heißt das ist der grund
warum sie jetzt auch sagen leute kommt
zurück zur arbeit arbeitet alle arbeitet
und auch die frauen weil sie die
brauchen aber wir wollen die die zahlen
die er halten ja und natürlich die frage
was wie schätzen sie das ein wie geht es
jetzt weiter mit der hilfe für
afghanistan mit projekten wie ihren was
ist da ihre zukunftsprognose
ich hoffe dass die deutschen
organisationen die macht vor ort sind
das die jetzt
keine verhandlungsmasse auch gekommen
von der deutschen regierung und das weil
wir werden jetzt schon dieses wochenende
anfang mit den taliban zu verhandeln und
das wird das nächste interessante sein
der mich ihnen zu sagen ich nehme die
patienten wieder auf wie geht ein
projekt wieder komma wenn die frauen bei
uns arbeiten dürfen und dann und wenn
sie ins internet gehen dürfen damit wir
ja sie können so damit sie uns
konsultieren können damit sie von uns
weitere bildung erfahren damit wir das
projekt leiten können und und und
es gibt bestimmte dinge die ich aus ganz
praktischen medizinischen gründen tun
muss damit dem projekt läuft und dann
bin ich mal schon gespannt ob das geht
und dass wir an die bedingungen und
weiterzuarbeiten die verhandlungsmasse
ja die könnte man jetzt eben deutschen
hilfsorganisationen geben die müssen
alle mit den taliban zu verhandeln um
ihre projekte weiter zu machen und es
gibt nicht viele vor ort aber die sind
klasse die deutschen organisationen die
da sind und die wissen was sie tun es
kommen jetzt keine neuen organisationen
nach afghanistan und da sind leute die
sind auch seit vielen jahren da und
denen sollte man jetzt verhandlungs
sicherheit geben wenn sie mir den
taliban sprechen denn was sie brauchen
ist ja
sozialministerium bei unseres das könnte
ich nicht machen was wir hier die 20
jahre aufgebaut haben dass es schaffen
den ich und dazu brauchen sie uns und
dazu scheinen sie uns auch haben zu
wollen und das würde ich gerne nutzen
also die entwicklungshilfe sollte man
auch in form von zahlungen die direkt
und die regierung gehen aber nicht
zahlungen die an deutsche
hilfsorganisationen gehen die noch
meinen und das sofort tätig sein können
das sind einige ich glaube dass die die
wissen was sie tun wir sind keine
durchgeknallten alt rüsten sagt zu
seiner liebe watts gründerin der
hilfsorganisation kinderberg vielen dank
frau die bereits für ihre zeit und dass
sie hier so viele fragen für uns
beantwortet haben
herzlichen dank
und dann kann natürlich auch für eben
eure diese fragen und dass er zugeschaut
habt und wir beobachten das thema
natürlich weiter und bis dahin zum
nächsten mal tschüss